so the traditional
so the story of genome maxwell is a dark
fairy story the darkest
one of the darkest you'll ever hear and
the thing about the story is that the
traditional version of it is seen
in the netflix um filthy rich
is there is only one monster on the
monsters jeffrey epstein
my version in hunting gerlain the
podcast and
later this year i'm going to write a
book uh about her
called probably hunting shalam after the
trial is over
suggests there's at least well there's
more than one monster the second monster
is her father who was a grossly abusive
man
who according to his own wife
betty maxwell who loved him for 40 years
more
said he um
took sadistic pleasure in humiliating
the people closest to him
his family he bullied psychologically
his family horribly he also
um may and the evidence of
for this is not clear
it's not clear but there is a woman with
mental health issues
who had an infatuation with robert
maxwell
and maxwell liked her as well i don't
know the nature of their relationship
but this woman is called elena berry and
she says at the age of nine
in a book she says that jalen maxwell
showed her various implements
of beating like um
a piece of leather a ruler a cane that
went swish
as you moved in the air and
and jillian age nine said to elena berry
daddy's nice because he lets me choose
what he's going to beat me with
i don't know whether that happened
um but it's a fact that robert maxwell
was an emotional bully a psychological
bully
who took as his wife said sadistic
pleasure
in humiliating his family so
my version of this dark story a dark
fairy story says there isn't
one monster it goes beyond the netflix
version and filthy rich there are two
monsters
there is jeffrey epstein and there is
robert maxwell
the question um that i
wrestle with is is jalen maxwell
the third monster have you
have you tried reaching out to her
directly to talk to her from the
through the prison bureau either not
through
she has a um a pr man
um and i've approached him while i was
making the podcast
it's available by the way on spotify and
apple all the usual places it's called
hunting gillen
um i pronounce yelen julen americans
pronounce you then
i thought it was lane uh jizzling is
wrong um as a joke
yeah yeah and the bad one
sorry the tequila's getting to me yeah
yeah yeah
yes drink advisably
so um the
so i i i and the thing is that i think
she was certainly a victim because her
father was a cruel bully
psychologically i don't know whether
this story about the beating is true
but but it kind of fits other stories
so it's grim
however i think that
you can be a victim and also a
perpetrator
and so the question is if you have been
abused yourself
or i've been mucked around
psychologically
[Music]
does that lessen your defenses
does it make it more likely that you
could abuse others
and i spoke to um in the podcast in
episode six
i spoke to a therapist who deals who
lives in l.a he deals with victims of
the church of scientology all the time
and she said it's commonplace for
victims who then turn into
become perpetrators and the problem is
if you're raised inside
a dark environment then that becomes
normal do you think because of her child
or her alleged childhood trauma do you
think that it's possible that she
possibly had
a no moral compass
yes i think that is um
that's where i sit on this
i feel that she didn't know
what was right and wrong where the
boundaries were
this is common now betty her mum
who loved robert maxwell who said that
for too long all of us
helped perpetuate his quotes cult
personality
now robert maxwell didn't run a cult
like scientology where you have
suckers on the knees paying for some
kind of
spiritual enlightenment because he had
his businesses which were working much
of the time
and that was the source of the money but
kind of a bit like putin um
a bit like others he didn't have enough
people around him saying
don't do this boss this is bad
um and if you've got a very very
powerful personality
and this guy was off the wall then
then what you create is a kind of cult
the problem for jalen was that she was
brought up
inside a cult a kind of a cult
so when she meets so her father dies
my view is he fell off the yacht
deliberately he committed suicide
he wasn't pushed that's my view i was
disputed
but when she lost one monster she went
to manhattan and found the second
jeffrey epstein
who was the same kind of guy brilliant
poor made a ton of money incredibly
manipulative
and abusive and his thing was
abusing these poor kids more child and
women
again and again and again and the
allegation against yelen is that she
made that happen she was a handmaiden to
that abuse
she denies it she denies all six charges
against her
and to be fair and proper we've got to
wait until the trial this summer
when we'll hear for the first time her
defense
now what drew your interest to
robert maxwell and his daughter i met
robert maxwell when i was a boy
really yeah um not when i was a boy when
i was how old are you
i'm 33. there was a charity event
i think if memory serves at great ormond
street hospital a kids hospital in
london
there's robert maxwell and there's
princess diana
and robert maxwell was laying on the
schmaltz
and there was something sickening and
wrong about him
then um what happened was
uh i you know i was fascinated by him
and i
can remember um in the summer 1991 he
died on november the 5th 1991
i proposed to the editor of the observer
my then newspaper
can i investigate robert maxwell no way
like the
editor donald trump has looked at me as
if i'd offered him a [ __ ] cow pact
a cow pat is you know what the camp out
is yeah
yeah then what's weird with american
english is that every now and then
everything goes wrong
and you don't understand there's a few
words i don't understand like thick and
thick it means stupid watching you and
shawn talk for two hours i
there was a couple of moments where i
was like what the [ __ ] are they talking
about because they're so wrong
anyway never mind um so
all right uh what were we talking about
we're talking about maxwell yeah
so there was something about maxwell
that i knew was wrong and i couldn't do
the story for my paper because
because he threatened to sue everybody
all the time so he was
he used um the libel laws in a
disgraceful way
then what happened was that he um
he ended up
falling off his yacht um just moving
a cable around because it wasn't going
to run out of gas
so we go to the supermarket my my
my then mrs um
and we hear on the news bbc radio robert
maxwell
has fallen off his yacht and
and the it says the supermarket has got
a roof
car park uh i'm on the roof car park
and my missus says well come on let's go
shopping and i said well i've got to
listen to this and the thing is
i've only just recovered from crying my
eyes out
i'm seeing a kid looking like my son so
the thing is i couldn't go anywhere
because i was in bits
i couldn't do this story and it kind of
hurt me
so 30 years on i leave the bbc
i want to do a podcast i go to lbc and i
say
i'd like to do hunting jalen because
she's gone she's gone missing
and um
they say yes but it takes them six
months to say yes
partly because of an election then the
virus hits it's all a mess but finally
they say yes
and they say yes on july the first or
rather i signed the contract on july the
1st
uh last year 2020
and she's arrested and the title of the
podcast is hunting jalen
i'm gonna find jalen right that's what
i'm going to do
and on july the 2nd the fbi find her
in new hampshire and i phone up the boss
i'll podcast chris bournemouth lbc and i
say
i've signed the contract i've signed the
contract
i just said john it's okay it's still
fascinating
how she did this how she hid how it
worked and the moment
i um i then go and see
i think the first thing i do is i see
the former editor of private eye which
is our wonderful satirical magazine in
britain
richard engrams who's an old friend of
mine
i um um done
some little bits and pieces for private
eyes since the 80s
and i've been to private eye lunches and
robert maxwell used to sue private eye
all the time
so often the richard ingrams who wrote
the stories who was the editor can't
remember how often he was sued
but um he
he hated maxwell when he was alive
but he feels sorry for jillian maxwell
because her father was such a monster